Oh
it's a real exciting day today because
I've got a visitor here Destin from the
channel smarter every day and not only
destined who'd be quite exciting in his
own right but much more exciting he's
brought a camera a very high-speed
camera called the Phantom Miro which can
record video extremely fast
several thousand frames a second so you
might ask why does that matter and the
answer is that many chemical reactions
are really really fast and so we're
really interested he's not a very good
actor isn't good you may ask why on
earth should we want a high-speed camera
and the answer is that chemical
reactions are very fast and we or least
I as a chemist have not seen these
reactions recorded at high speed and I
believe and I think Brady does as well
that some of our reactions might look
quite different when we video them at a
high speed and we've done quite a lot of
videoing and we're going to do some more
as a taster of what we're going to
upload over the next few months I
thought you'd like to see one or two
clips just to see quite how amazing this
high-speed camera can make chemistry
appear even more exciting than I thought
I'm very happy to be here I don't really
think I can express how happy I am to
view
[Music]
and when you heat it up some of the
liquids going to boil so it'll create
the pressure of steam I was trying not
to pee my pants I got it
[Music]
and then probably it will be continued
from the register
[Music]
Wow
and I should just end by saying that not
only is destined come with the camera
but he also came and brought me two
presents he brought me a periodic table
shower-curtain they're not quite sure
where I'm going to hang it
Brady thinks I should put it on the
window behind and he's also brought a
fantastic tie which says removed before
flight and I'm not sure whether I should
wear this when I'm traveling on
aeroplanes well perhaps I will wear it
in one of our videos so watch and you
might see when I'm wearing it